soyez vous sur la chaise de gabriel vous
méritez bien ça la comédienne
marie-thérèse fortin a fait un cadeau à
colombes phare chartier grande
admiratrice de gabrielle roy et bénévole
à la maison d'enfance de l'auteur
originaire de saint boniface
la comédienne a invité la franco
manitobaine de passage à montréal a
monté sur scène et a discuté de sa
nouvelle pièce qui reprend des écrits de
gabrielle roy
on dirait que je parle d'un quatrième
avec cette humiliation de voir quelqu'un
se retourner sur moi qui parlais
français dans une rue de winnipeg
gabrielle roy habite marie thérèse
fortin qui joue le rôle de sa vie dans
la pièce la détresse et l'enchantement
un montage de phrases tirées entre
autres de l'autobiographie de
l'écrivaine l'auteur du roman bonheur
d'occasion fascine depuis toujours la
comédienne je trouve que c'est une
immense auteur qui est pas seulement une
grande hauteur canadien c'est une grande
hauteur internationale et je vous la
ramenez je veux que les jeunes à
découvrir je veux que les jeunes lisent
ce que parce que je trouve que pour les
jeunes femmes et quelque chose nous
d'aller chercher puiser c'est vrai que
le malheur nous poursuit depuis
longtemps faudrait sans doute remonter
bien loin pour en connaître la cause
tu ne dis si la détresse et
l'enchantement puis c'est la grande
traversée d'une femme vers
l'émancipation et la pleine autonomie
des foires est en répétition avec
alliance dénommée stas a pas de danses
apprises nécessaire et plus précieux à
l'être humain
que sa liberté pendant 90 minutes marie
thérèse fortin porte sur ses épaules
c'est quand pages de texte un véritable
tour de force pour donner une seconde
vie aux phrases c'est à se demander
comment il s'y prend parce que les
olympiques sont pas finis pour tout le
monde non mais en même temps si je
pensais les japonais qui disent ça le
plaisir vient avec la maîtrise
n'empêche qu'il m'arrive parfois de
sentir à travers l'estiment dont on
entoure surtout peut-être à cause de
bonheur d'occasion comme un regret
madame sa part chartier a été bouleversé
par la pièce 5 touche à beaucoup parce
que je j'ai une mère comme sommes aussi
qui s'est toujours dévoué pour toutes
les eaux de la détresse et de
l'enchantement il s'accompagne louis
philippe ouimet radio canada montréal